je trouve bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec et sur rt france alors la bulgarie
a fait le choix de maintenir le scrutin
malgré la crise sanitaire quelles
conséquences sur le taux de
participation à ces élections
législatives alors je dirais que c'est
pas seulement lié à la crise sanitaire
c'est vraiment une participation qui
s'annonce relativement faible comme à
son habitude en bulgarie en fait il faut
voir que depuis le début de la
transition politique entre systèmes
connus des systèmes libéral en bulgarie
comme dans beaucoup de pays des balkans
d'ailleurs il ya une intention
relativement forte
d'autant plus que boiko borisov est
quand même entâché d'une réputation de
corruption ce qui amènera les gens à
vraiment sortir le moins possible
et puis dernier point contrairement au
voisin
faire beau macedonia qui ont mieux géré
la crise du coc vide
c'est vrai que maintenant monte en
bulgarie une crainte par rapport à cette
pandémie
justement la mauvaise gestion de
l'épidémie de covile 19 mais aussi
l'apparition de ces mouvements de
contestation anti corruption depuis
l'été dernier
cela risque-t-il de fragiliser la
position du premier ministre oui non en
fait non quand on analyse la situation
en bulgarie
ils voulaient le le résultat est
pratiquement inéluctable c'est à dire
une victoire de borisov pourquoi parce
qu'il est quand même et tient les rênes
du pouvoir depuis un certain temps et
que son parti est quand même majoritaire
à la fois dans les régions et les les
communes qui s'appelle les municipalités
en bulgarie donc de ce fait là
contrairement à nous c'est un parti que
quand même assez monolithique mais ce
sera une victoire relativement courte
une très courte et dans un système
parlementaire qui est un système à la
britannique où il faut des coalitions et
bien ça l'amènera à composer avec
d'autres partis ce qu'on a vu récemment
monténégro par exemple après 30 ans de
pouvoir d'un nex apparatchiks
communistes et bien il ya maintenant une
coalition conservatrice qui est obligé
de travailler avec trois partis
différents
donc je pense qu'en bulgarie on aura
exactement la même situation c'est à
dire une courte victoire du mai du parti
majoritaire mais qui sera obligé de
mener le pays avec une coalition
parlementaire
alors depuis presque 11 ans quasiment
borisov est à la tête du gouvernement en
bulgarie est-ce que cela atteste d'une
faiblesse de la part de l'opposition
sans aucun doute
et ça c'est vrai on retrouve ça aussi
dans beaucoup de pays de la région c'est
à dire qu'une opposition qui se
chamaillent constamment entre hans
bigeard dans une option il n'entrait
souris non pas choisir entre l'option
royalistes et l'option démocratique je
rappeler aux auditeurs que dans le pays
voisin roumanie les gens sont revenus à
la monarchie et donc ça c'est un débat
encore très fort en bulgarie tu donc
entre monarchie et république ni aux
sirènes de la république il y a des
messieurs une sorte de maladies
congénitales
dans beaucoup de pays où le transition
se fait c'est à dire que la liberté très
mal utilisé et utilisés à mauvais
escient
il ya sans arrêt des débats assez
violent au parlement ddd scandale qui
sortent dans les journaux et dans cette
ambiance c'est vrai que c'est ce qui
amène la population à être assez rétive
aux élections alors vous avez parlé
d'une possible courte victoire en tout
cas du parti du premier ministre
borisov avec qui justement faudra-t-il
voilà nouer des alliances pour parvenir
à une majorité
et bien moi je je pense qu'il sera
peut-être obligé dans une alliance avec
les anciens du parti socialiste en fait
les ancien communiste reconverti au
socialiste et donc on verra une sorte de
coalition
un peu à l'allemande entre conservateurs
et socialistes estimé dans le pays
parce que or hormis les socialistes tous
les autres partis sont relativement
minoritaire donc pour avoir une position
tellement relativement simple table
pardon eh bien ça sera vraiment cette
alliance entre conservateurs et
socialistes a laissé trop de merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur en
géographie géopolitique spécialiste des
balcons